he'll enjoy his moment in the spotlight
it's been a long time coming the Open
champion spent all night celebrating
Darren Clarke arrived back in Northern
Ireland
and headed straight for the pub the Open
champion had been looking forward to a
pint on home turf all day it'll be
special this afternoon when I go back
home and the two boys we got the trophy
the Claret Jug in their in their hands
that would be when it probably starts
sickening but it's been great but I want
more I don't want to just rest someone
and hopefully our chance for more meters
these were the scenes back home as the
42 year old clinched his maiden major at
his local in Bushmills they could not be
more proud of their popular customer the
genuine lakum suddenly has a few paints
so of the backstop as he calls it and
enjoys himself the negative surface I'm
here patiently pathology and they can
talk to people just be contented Darren
Clarke was heartbroken when his wife
Heather died of cancer in 2006 he
returned home to Northern Ireland to
raise his sons among family and friends
this community embraced him and
continued to believe he could win a
major to suggest he has rewarded them
for that support would be an
understatement
Darren Clarke is the third Northern
Ireland golfer in 14 months
to win a major it's an incredible
achievement for a country with a
population of less than two million the
resilience he's shown both on and off
the course has earned him many fans
Clark's now engaged to Alison Campbell a
former Miss Northern Ireland 13 year old
Tyrone Clarke says he's very proud of
what his dad has achieved his brother
Connor who's 11 is more interested in
how they'll spend the winnings
David Blevins Sky News at royal Portrush